et bien grégory voici la nouvelle
attestation de déplacement dérogatoire
un document édité par le ministère de
l'intérieur et que vous pouvez retrouver
sur le site interieur.gouv.fr cette
nouvelle attestation a fait suite aux
annonces et aux précisions apportées par
le premier ministre edouard philippe
par rapport aux mesures du confinement
par exemple on retrouve des nouveaux un
motif comme la convocation judiciaire ou
administrative ou la participation à des
missions d'intérêt général sur demande
de l'autorité administrative
autre précision en lien avec l'activité
physique
ce déplacement devrait être bref dans la
limite d'une heure quotidienne et dans
un rayon d'un kilomètre autour de votre
domicile
dernière nouveauté il faudra préciser
l'horaire de sortie mais la seule règle
qui reste la même c'est bien de rester à
votre domicile